welcome back okay we're talking about
dynamical systems and in the last
lecture we talked about continuous time
dynamical systems X dot equals f of X
and I want to be explicit that this
state X depends on T so the time
derivative of x equals some function of
X this is just how we write down
differential equations where some state
vector X evolves in time this could be
the populations of a predator and a prey
species and they as they evolve in time
or anything else okay so very very
general ordinary differential equation
framework or dynamical systems framework
this is called a continuous time system
and what I want to talk about today is
how we can get discrete time dynamical
systems from these okay so discrete time
dynamical systems and when I write this
X I'm going to assume that this is
possibly a vector of states and so this
F would have be a vector valued function
with as many outputs as there are
elements of X and so for every
continuous differential equation you can
define a discrete time differential
equation or dynamical system
corresponding to this so what we're
going to say is X at k plus 1 equals big
f at x at time k so usually I think of
the the index K as the time step of an
integrator so I'm stepping my system
forward in time from time k to kind of
time k plus 1 but in reality this could
be much more general this doesn't have
to be time discrete time dynamical
systems are more general than continuous
time systems ok and what i could do is i
could define i could define x at time k
to be this continuous x at time k delta
t so again i could be taking delta t
time steps maybe i have a real
continuous physical system like a
population but i sample it every day and
so my delta t might be one-day sampling
and k would be you know k equals 1 would
be day 1
would be day 2 day 3 and so on and so
forth so what I could do is I could
sample my continuous time system and
then I could essentially write my my big
F in terms of this continuous time
differential equation I could basically
say how do I want to find this I could
basically say X at time k plus 1 is
equal to X at time k plus the integral
from K delta T to k plus 1 Delta t of f
of X of what's called this tau X of tau
D tau so essentially what I can do is I
can integrate my trajectory through this
dynamical system for 1 delta T and and
that will give me my next time step X at
k plus 1 so oftentimes we call this the
flow map the flow map so this flows my
state from one time into the future
according to this differential equation
and that's called the flow map F this is
my little delta T flow map ok so f delta
T big f delta T as a flow map through
delta T of this and it steps me delta T
forward ok and notice I have to write it
as an integral so basically I start at
XK and then what this is my initial
condition and then essentially I am
integrating this right hand side
continuously but as I integrate this
right hand side continuously my state X
is moving along with the dynamics so I
have to keep track of where my state
moves along this trajectory so that's
when I have this X of tau inside of here
because as the state is moving my vector
field has to be evaluated at that new
location throughout this trajectory ok
so I can always go from continuous time
to discrete time this is really
important you can always go this way
but you can only sometimes come back so
discrete time dynamical systems are much
more general there's more discrete time
dynamical systems than there are
continuous time every single continuous
time dynamical system can be written in
discrete time using this flow map but
there are lots of discrete time
dynamical systems where there is no
continuous time analog where they're not
integrating some continuous time process
so one example could be in real
population dynamics there are these
discrete events and seasons and things
like that so it's hard to model you know
population dynamics as a continuous time
system if there really are these kind of
discrete events that happen like you
know there's spring and there's winter
and things like that okay one way that
you can picture what this what this flow
map is doing is we can try to just look
at what a forward Euler integrator would
look like okay so instead of writing X
dot let's say X at time k plus 1 minus X
at time K divided by delta T equals f of
X and let's say it's f of X at time K
okay I'm gonna do a super simple
approximation this is approximately
equal let's say approximately okay XK
minus one XK plus one minus XK divided
by delta T this is a finite difference
approximation of this derivative here is
approximately equal to F evaluated at XK
and now I can multiply everything over
and I get XK plus 1 equals XK plus delta
T times F of XK so notice this actually
looks a lot like this expression here
where I've done the crudest kind of left
rectangle approximation of this integral
over that delta T so instead of
integrating over delta T this F function
I'm literally just taking that F holding
it constant and multiplying it by delta
T so if my function f
looked like that you know from k to k
plus 1 this is f then what this forward
Euler integrator is doing is it's just
holding it constant for that entire
delta T and it's computing this integral
area just using the area that's
rectangle so that's what this is here
it's kind of a crummy left rectangle
approximation of this true flow map so
there is a true flow map and forward
Euler this is a forward Euler integrator
is basically just doing an approximation
of that of that flow map ok so this is
kind of the crudest simplest thing you
would code up if you wanted to simulate
a dynamical system as you'd basically
just make this approximation for the
derivative you multiply by delta T at XK
and now you have an integrator ok and
this is crudely approximating this flow
map there are lots and lots of
discrete-time systems that you could
induce from this continuous-time I could
write down the Runge Kutta integrator
family and each of those is another
discrete-time flow map that's
approximating this true continuous
integral flow map in most systems of
interest you can't actually compute this
integral in closed form so really only a
very small handful of dynamical systems
can you actually write down the annex
analytic solution to this for linear
systems you can do it this will be e to
the a T where a is the the linear matrix
a times X but really in general for
nonlinear dynamical systems this flow
map is hard to compute ok and you have
to approximate it numerically with with
schemes like this but in general I think
one of the points I want to make is that
these discrete-time systems are more
general ok so this is more general and
even very very simple systems can give
rise to chaos okay so one system in the
next video we're going to simulate the
logistic map so let me just write it up
here we're gonna simulate up the
logistic map and this is actually
another model for population growth and
saturation so it's got
these kind of different fixed points
corresponding to zero population or full
population and as we dial up one of the
parameters we're going to find that this
actually goes chaotic okay so the
dynamical system I believe is XK plus 1
equals beta X K beta times X K times 1
minus XK okay and so this is a simple
nonlinear map that is XK minus XK
squared times a beta parameter and as
this beta increases the system is going
to become more and more and more chaotic
okay so we're going to simulate this in
MATLAB and plot some really cool
pictures that you've probably seen
before okay thank you